[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir ce soir c'est en tant
que citoyenne maman et professionnels de
l'éducation que je suis venu vous parler
d'un thème qui me vient qui ne tient
vraiment à coeur
l'école mais avant tout souvenez vous
quand vous étiez à l'école c'était quoi
votre moment préféré moi c'était la
récréation je me souviens quand la
cloche sonnait on descendait on allait
jouer aux billes avec les copines on se
courait après puis on se racontait les
secrets je me sentais vivante et libre
à ce moment là et puis plus tard en
préparant mon concours d'institutrice et
en travaillant en école primaire c'était
toujours mon moment préféré
et puis avec mon regard d'adulte je
voyais les enfants et toute cette
énergie créatrice et je me demandais où
ça passait quand on rentrait dans la
classe mais je pense que ça restait dans
la cour de récréation
là où cet espace de liberté leur
permettait d'exister et puis je me
posais aussi toutes ces questions quelle
part active laisse-t-on aux enfants dans
leur apprentissage
comment peuvent-ils se responsabiliser
dans les décisions qui les concernent et
comment laisser vivre ce qui les rend
uniques
j'étais convaincu qu'on devait pouvoir
être soi même dalle écoles et à partir
de là je me suis en tête de trouver un
lieu où ma fille romane pourraient se
sentir libres d'être elle-même
développer son potentiel et son
autonomie et après quelques recherches
l'école démocratique semblait répondre à
toutes mes questions et y en avait pas à
côté de rennes donc je me suis dit
pourquoi pas la créer cette école
l'école noesis existe depuis un petit
peu plus d'un an
elle a vu le jour grâce à l'énergie de
plein de personnes convaincues exposant
ces mêmes questions alors une école
démocratique c'est quoi un espace de
grande liberté et de responsabilité
ici les jeunes conduisent leur vie
librement qu'ils choisissent les
activités qui vont rythmer leur journée
ils sont libres de vivre avec intensité
et sans limite de temps tout ce qui les
anime
tout ce qui les anime et sont libres
aussi de ne rien faire parce que l'ennui
a toute sa place
alors tous les enfants vous et moi y
compris ceux menés avec une curiosité
innée une envie de jouer et un profond
désir d'apprendre et jouer librement va
permettre de rester connecté à cet élan
d'apprentissage naturel et je vais vous
dire une bonne partie de tout ce que le
joli favorise le développement physique
cognitif celui du cerveau des muscle
cardiaque
il favorise la réflexion l'argumentation
la pensée hypothétique le langage la
capacité à développer de la méthode à
s'organiser
c'est fou tout ce qui se passe non et
tout ça rien quand on joue en librement
pourtant le jeu libre a tendance à
disparaître de plus en plus des cours de
récréation des écoles de nos foyers
parce que jugée moins efficace que des
activités plus formatrices et nous à
l'école bien cette liberté va permettre
par exemple à quentin 10 ans de suivre
son centre d'intérêt du moment la
robotique
alors que même moment sophie 13 ans elle
préférera participer à un atelier de
création de savon et alexandre trois ans
lui fabrique des cabanes avec sa copine
marine
cette liberté de choisir permet à chaque
enfant de vivre des défis à sa portée et
les réussites qui vont avec
alors toute la semaine à noé this se
croisent des enfants de trois à vingt
ans un accès à une richesse humaine et
une diversité incroyable mais le multi
âges ne s'arrête pas là parce que nous
aussi les adultes faisons partie de
cette richesse humaine jusqu'à notre
doyenne de 73 ans alors vous imaginez la
diversité des points de vue des centres
d'intérêt et des passions de 3 à 73 ans
ça va de la création d'un jeu vidéo sur
scratch en passant par la danse bretonne
l'équitation mais on se nourrit de ce
foisonnement et on apprend en passant
les revenons à ce cours de robotique il
n'est pas obligatoire et tant mieux
parce que si romane sept ans avait été
obligé de lui participé elle se serait
ennuyé à mourir elle ce qu'elle aime
c'est être dehors à regarder les petites
bêtes et à savoir comment elle va
pouvoir préserver la nature alors que ça
aurait été dommage pour gabin de louper
ça à quatre ans et demi lui il a dedans
regarder quand un programme et faire
fonctionner son robot à l'école
démocratique c'est la vie quitte
enseigne le plus chacun ville influence
des autres et la nécessité d'avancer
vers la connaissance de soi pour se
démarquer en tant qu'individu à noé this
on apprend à se connaître à savoir qu'on
aime ce qui nous motive ce qui nous est
facile et ce qu'ils nous demandent plus
d'efforts et ce dans quoi on est bien au
point d'en oublier le temps qui passe et
tout ça sans jugement la curiosité n'est
pas un vilain défaut comme on nous l'a
souvent dit au contraire c'est être
connectés à cette envie d'apprendre pour
et par soi même
chaque jour pleinement investi focaliser
sur l'instant présent avec sa tête son
corps et son coeur à noisy s'il n'y a
pas de masque pas de rôles à jouer
chacun apprend à composer avec la vraie
personnalité des gens en toute
authenticité
alors pour nous permettre de tous vivre
ensemble il y à un cadre des limites de
sécurité des règles mais celles ci sont
codées fini discuter remise en question
qu'on ait quatre ans ou 40 ans parce
qu'un enfant égale une voix et un adulte
égale une voix ici la démocratie ça
s'enseigne pas ça se vit par exemple à
l'ouverture de l'école on pouvait manger
là où on voulait y a pas de règle à ce
niveau là est tout le monde mangeait
partout et puis quand on s'est rendu
compte qu'on avait duré la sauce tomate
collé sous les pieds on s'est dit ah non
il faut faire quelque chose
donc a été proposé à l'ensemble du
collectif une règle qui dit il est
interdit de manger à l'extérieur de la
cafétéria et puis pendant qu'on
débattait du pourquoi de cette règle un
jeune a exprimé de l'injustice parce que
lui faisait attention et puis d'autres
aussi alors pourquoi payer pour tout le
monde et de discussion en discussion un
élève a proposé la mise en place d'un
certificat
comme ça chacun prend sa responsabilité
de perdre ou de conserver la possibilité
de manger à l'extérieur de la caf est ce
genre d'exemple il y en a plein à noé
this parce qu'une banale expérience du
quotidien va nous faire prendre
conscience qu'il est nécessaire
d'ajouter une règle de la modifier ou de
la supprimer
parce qu'elle perd de son sens tout
simplement l'adulte n'est pas l'autorité
de l'école l'autorité est partagé chacun
prend la responsabilité de s'y sentir
bien et respecté alors vous imaginez ce
que ça peut représenter pour un enfant
d'évoluer dans un milieu comme celui là
c'est très constructif pour sa
personnalité parce que tu en grande
partie grâce à ça qu'il saura qui il est
qu'il apprendra à se connaître et c'est
aussi ça qui lui permettra d'apprendre à
diriger sa vie en suivant son instinct
pourtant l'instinct nous fait souvent
malheureusement défaut parce que à
toujours vouloir nous dire ce qu'il est
bon ce qu'il faut faire
notre modèle éducatif nous fait souvent
malheureusement passé complètement à
côté de qui on est
de ce qu'on aime de nos besoins
physiologiques on ne sait tout
simplement plus écoutée on fait les
choses pour convenir aux attentes
on fait les choses on organise nos
journées de façon très mécanique et moi
je le vois tous les jours à noisy un
enfant libre de manger s'arrêtera de
manger quand il n'aura plus fin un
enfant libre de dormir ira se coucher
quand il aura vraiment sommeil et un
enfant libre de jouer apprendre à ce qui
l'intéresse
mais il l'apprendra martin est arrivé à
l'école à 5 ans et demi à ce moment là
il ne savait pas lire
et puis six mois après sans méthode
particulière ni à l'école ni à la maison
martin nle il n'avait pas besoin de
méthodes ils étaient prêts et comme ça
faisait sens pour lui il a appris pas
d'attentes de rentabilité il apprend à
son rythme c'est comme l'apprentissage
de la marche au moment où ça fait sens
pour un enfant de se mettre debout et de
marché il le fait grandir
c'est un processus permanent
d'adaptation au monde mais s'adapter ne
veut pas dire se conformer ou s'oublier
pour répondre à une norme et comme
l'enfant l'école démocratique est un
système organique et adaptable c'est un
lieu vivant qui évolué pour s'adapter
aux besoins de son collectif est aussi
créé les métiers de demain alors
parlons-en du milieu professionnel
aujourd'hui qu'attend-t-on d'une
personne dans un milieu professionnel
je vais noté parce que c'était trop long
j'avais pas envie de la prendre
vous êtes prêts
de l'engagement de l'autonomie pour la
résolution de problèmes complexes de
l'esprit critique de la créativité être
collaboratif coopératif faire preuve
d'intelligence émotionnelle d'excellence
et en même temps faire simple avoir du
sens de la négociation faire preuve de
flexibilité mentale être adaptable
organisé prendre des initiatives faire
preuve de motivation et d'engagement et
ça c'est sans parler des compétences
techniques
la liste est terriblement longue et ça
peut paraître effrayant et ça me semble
même pas faire le lien avec tout ce
qu'on m'a enseignées à l'école et en
oasis joie des enfants de 5 ans qui
cumule déjà tous ces savoirs être que
c'est clair ils ont le job c'est
vraiment pour ça que je crois que les
écoles démocratiques sont un terreau
pour l'innovation et la construction du
monde de demain alors vous vous demandez
maintenant sûrement qu'est ce que ça
donne toute cette liberté que devient-il
des enfants rois incapable de suivre des
règles d'écouté est-ce qu'ils pourront
s'adapter dans une société fait de
contraintes
est-ce qu'ils pourront retourner dans un
système plus traditionnel des marais des
études supérieures alors il faut savoir
que ces écoles existe depuis 100 ans
pour la plus ancienne et on al'avantage
d'avoir suffisamment de recul pour
savoir ce qu'ils deviennent et ne
deviennent pas tous à 82% intègre des
études supérieures d'autres suivent des
voix d'apprentissage technique mais dans
tous les cas ils suivent une direction
qui les inspirent qui les motive à se
dépasser pour accéder au projet
professionnel qu'ils ont choisi et qui
fait sens pour eux et ils t'ont porté
par une grande conviction d'avoir fait
le juste choix et de la confiance en eux
et ça c'est pas rien alors vous vous
demandez sûrement
est ce que moi je serai capable
aujourd'hui de mettre mon enfant dans ce
type d'école est ce que vous vous seriez
capable
est ce que vous seriez capable vous et
vous
faire ce choix demande du courage parce
que il n'ya pas d'enseignement dirigé
pas de programme pas de devoirs et pas
d'autres évaluations que celle du jeune
lui-même et c'est difficile quand on vit
dans une société qui demande en
permanence des chiffres des résultats et
cherche à nous coller dans des cases
mais pourtant
permettons-nous et permettons à nos
enfants d'avancer et de prendre le temps
d'aller à la rencontre de soi de suivre
son instinct de choisir et de mettre du
sang sur tous ces apprentissages qu'on
ait quatre ans ou 40 ans je suis fier de
contribuer à l'équilibré du monde de
demain en m'impliquant chaque jour dans
cette école parce que je pense que
personnellement l'éducation pause au
sens plus large ces questions quel
enfant allons nous laisser à notre
planète seront ils suffisamment préparés
pour porter avec force tous ces
changements qui s'imposent pour la
survie de notre terre moi je dit un
grand oui pour ceux qui auront appris à
s'aimer et aimer la vie qui les entoure
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]